hey guys come see me on the road if you
already have tickets to skank Fest in
Vegas come see me there if not that
baby's sold out but next you can see me
in Irvine California San Jose I'll be in
Michigan and Florida and many other
places go to annieleterman.com shows you
can also hear me on my audio show on
Spotify live don't bore me every Monday
night check it out it's on all my
socials and Annie wood is coming soon so
follow Annie Letterman on YouTube
you guys it's time to talk about female
hair thinning over half a woman will
experience hair thinning in their
lifetime it's totally normal your hair
story could help another woman join the
conversation at shed the silence.com
that's shed the silence.com
foreign
[Music]
and that hair texture was in your
picture was giving me like
my dad pops almost called him daddy that
was weird uh my dad is weird too pops uh
my father Bob sounds like you did bang
but like you want to put distance
between it you ever considered that do
Sons never call their dad's daddy or
when is that what age is that uh depends
on the lights on or off you kiss your
dad in the mouth dude you love yourself
yeah up until I was like 17. you know
then I got my driver's permit I was like
the [ __ ] away from you kiss you in the
mouth anymore dude yeah get off me Daddy
yeah Daddy no uh Dada that was probably
so I was like 14. we can move this board
this way a little bit what is this uh
topics when you start boring us yeah
this early I'm not bored I'm not bored
at all my dad I feel like I should be
wearing my sunglasses I'm having such a
good time yeah is that when you know
you're [ __ ] you're like on one
well I took that could you tell I was on
Xanax yesterday no I've been stressed
out I had it like obviously not enough
I've had no I know but then it's like my
arms felt heavy for the rest of the day
I was like I'm never taking I was I was
wait why would you take it just because
I'm stressed out because of my [ __ ]
cold I just have had a cold and I just
like I don't know I just was like you
didn't want to do like four seated I
just like I don't know I just like I'm
not sleeping I keep having dreams I keep
telling I'm having dreams where I can't
run my last one was I can't run the week
last week I couldn't scream no but the
week before she was like on a golf
course in space like well oh that was
cool you might have even been on it oh
it was a lot of comics it was there
there was like a there was a slide it's
a Burt Chrysler Festival but I was so
maybe were you on the bird
what did you get invited on the burp the
next one did you get invited on the last
one no yeah we'll be on the next one
guys are you really she's just trying to
get on no no we will be we will be yeah
yeah I will he was just trying to get
out of the way like the hacks and he
wanted to get like the real comics in
the next one so we'll be on that oh
interesting oh interesting okay bring up
topics now I'm bored now I'm bored you
know what I'm bored are you Bert whoa uh
no Bert's great I he's literally it's
whatever he's doing is great whatever
the next event is ever he's doing is
great that sounds so rude it's because I
wasn't invited there's passive
aggressive tones why the next Festival
is that a goddamn Ikea let me do 12
minutes let me try to Ikea you can go on
but you could never leave it's like
Hotel California why did you look so
seductively in the camera when you said
this was that seductive yeah you can I
don't know my sex levels I don't know
when I'm being sexy really yeah I know I
know do you think being in like in the
in the comedic brain sense it's harder
to flirt I don't know I'm so bad about
it I would just aggressively I would
like cartoonishly flirt with guys okay
I'd be like so let's see how two Comics
could flirt with each other it's awkward
it's real emotions it's like a chess
match yeah it's not good it's it turns
into therapy quickly you know because
it's like five minutes like oh this is
fun this is great then you're like I
don't know sometimes I'll just look at
my video views and they're down below
and I just feel like I did my mom an
excuse to like yeah my grades are good
enough yeah exactly but I'm curious so
how both of you I mean how do you kind
of
I don't know I don't know I I just feel
like how do we flirt no I'm saying
because you're kind of coming at it from
a creative or like comic perspective
I don't know I just I feel like I
struggle with it because my goal is to
like not my goal but what I'm used to is
self-deprecating right right she was
being like Oh well I'm such a [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] me you know who do you want to sell
my tiny tits the tiniest tits you've
ever seen
I think that I don't use words like you
just know that I'm interested just based
on like my number you did squish those
titties up a little bit
right now damn
pillows over your laps you guys I really
honestly you guys are erect right now
what's happening I have like a I have
like a it's a pleather fupa right now so
I the people I could do this
but that's not comfortable
you look like the first lady
you feel like you're mourning the queen
sometimes people tell me sometimes
people have like been like you look like
Hillary Clinton I'm like Fair Hillary
Clinton back in the day and I'm gonna
say you also look like Hillary wait no
Hillary Clinton was no got hotter as she
is do we not look like young Hillary
Clinton the two of us yeah you do you
look like Chelsea both of you
way Ruder honestly Chelsea I honestly oh
yep never mind Hillary Clinton that's
okay well that's two yards I look like
um
wait back to your question though about
flirting yeah I think what I'm saying
the content of what I'm saying saying
never changes it's just my proximity to
you okay so if I'm flirting let's say
for if I'm not flirting you'll feel her
breath on your neck right no that's
exactly it interesting so it's like we
could be talking covert was rough for
her like awesome nobody knows or
artificial plants yeah yeah and it'd be
regular it's still regular conversation
when I'm flirting it's just real close
like I inch closer and closer really
that's the only difference wow I
where did you get those jeans from yeah
so everybody at a concert thinks that
you're into that right exactly
Trevor and I've been doing some pretty
epic concerts together honestly we did
we went to a Green Day
[ __ ] Festival life is beautiful in
Vegas oh in Vegas oddly really fun I
know it was so fun I honestly life is
relatively attractive is how I felt
about the audience but I had a lot of
fun and I think I took a page out of
yearbook and I just kind of had like
instead of being like so like I need
these jokes to work I need to wear jeans
shorts you know steam my t-shirt I wore
like short neon shorts and a pink cowboy
hat yeah and I felt good about it yeah
this is like who gives them mushrooms
because people are eating mushrooms
those music festivals that have Comics
like is that always like a nightmare
uniformly you would think this one was
inside and oh it was actually it was
inside they actually did all the shows
like packed it was actually good and
everybody did like 20 minutes yeah which
is a perfect amount of Comedy for
somebody who's on ketamine right
they're like everybody
we're gonna have like a
like a fast good show and then we're all
gonna get [ __ ] up on much Green Day I
didn't stay I missed Billy eilish sorry
[ __ ]
um but I saw Ludacris did you go to
Ludacris I did ludicrous was hilarious
you know I just listened to the entire
Word of Mouth album again like three oh
yeah it's a [ __ ] Master he's great
but what was funny was seeing Ludacris
in like 2022 because now he's like PC
he's like where's all my [ __ ] [ __ ]
at that are respectfully getting equal
pay because everyone I swear to you and
he kept going you kept going like this
song came out 20 years ago I was like
don't say time we're on mushrooms no
time there's no time like we're all
dying no y'all again old did he sing
area codes of course yeah he goes he was
like he's literally said he's like he's
like he's like I've got hoes in
respectful area code literally like made
it an effort to be like I am PC Luna is
that a cup of noodles I'm gonna try I'm
gonna try to just eat I've never really
is that why you guys had to push the
podcast 30 minutes today I thought you
pushed it I thought you guys pushed I
did I um I have a SLAP tear on my
shoulder don't be worried about it
my shoulder
damn yeah she's ripped right off
learning too hard what happened oh Jesus
Christ really single she's just yeah
being single is really tricky well okay
I am also uh
oh sure
no she's still a great person we're on
good terms I talked to her yesterday
with the um the Range Rover yeah the car
yes she had a nice car than me I just
had to be like we're done what kind of
car did you drive in here oh Tesla I got
a Tesla you're dead yes why uh no I got
a three okay what color black with the
white seeds White seeds I got that cream
pie baby
we're getting a Tesla no it is a
different lifestyle I literally had to
order it like eight months ago like it
was really you're on your way out of the
relationship no things are going good
it's just uh yeah there's so much of
what the schedule is like our times
where she worked office hours and I was
doing stuff and then stand up at night
it just did you do videos with you no I
could never I like I met her once so I'm
always like is that her every time I see
you with a video oh no no no she didn't
but um we're still in good terms I just
you know we just maybe not right now
maybe later but I liked your tricky for
my for me it's like Bobby cannot stop
showing me girls he's going on dates
with interesting and it's like hey slow
down a bit you know but it's he's always
hot well one of them is so hilarious he
went on a date with a girl on Sunday you
know and apparently she was like she
didn't know who he was but she was like
wait a second you look familiar she's
like oh
um I know your girlfriend I'm a big fan
of her show so I felt like that was such
a win for me oh so she didn't know who
Bobby was but she knew this show she's
like are you remind me of a picture
behind my favorite yeah yeah I think so
so she can we take it down
all right tell me when you're ready and
then let's take it down no I love him I
want to keep him close always right
that's how I feel in my relationship
like I still love her as a person I
still want to like wait we should set
Bobby up with your ex-girlfriend
yeah yeah
I'm a [ __ ] yenta [ __ ] is that not a
great idea
I saw Bobby last night he got that new
car that's a buzz [ __ ] wagon I know
because he went from the Prius to like a
[ __ ] like nice ass car where you got
a crunch crunch crunch when you get in
yeah I'm sure the car inside smells like
Cheetos but the outside looks great it's
the first car he's actually truly taken
care of is it still brilliant yeah it's
still clean I was making a bet with him
but he walked away in the middle of the
bed what was the bet it was just gonna
be like at a certain day I was gonna put
it in my phone if you're he's like no
I'm keeping that it's like there's no
way you're gonna keep it clean you are
who you are it's impossible in one year
he's gonna try he isn't who he is like
no long he is no longer who he was for
nine years like he is on medication now
like things are working out because of
even though he's uh he had untreated
ADHD for so long so he never really had
like the patience to kind of see through
the task look I feel that I'm a tree I
have had treated add for a very long
time yeah you're eating a cup of noodle
over pillows things are not going well
what I'm trying to say is the best I've
been doing in a month buddy this is me
and my best baby I'm peeking no you're
doing great but I am saying like like
and you we live in the same part of town
when you have to drive like 45 minutes
for spots it's like you're eating
protein bars there's five of our
energies there's iced coffees all over
the car it's like you want to be clean
but then you just start having shows and
your time schedule gets [ __ ] up and
then you look back and you're like why
there's a recycling plant in my back
seat like I gotta fish my friend calls
it the ball pit sure it comes in kicks
her feet around hilarious yeah
you need something there's always
something back there yeah uh yeah
running shoes or nunchucks or just about
sometimes it is like I'm like do I have
Bo or did I leave a hoagie in the back
seat like it is like that sometimes
when you only get hoagies in
Philadelphia well I guess they're called
Subs
listen boys think they're better than us
they think they got more going on than
this
they're not the only ones that have
thinning hair we ladies this is feminism
baby okay we also have thinning hair in
fact when I stop taking birth control in
my late 20s all of a sudden my hair
started thinning in ways like I could
have never imagined because I had a
whole full head um head of hair and all
all of a sudden it was like half of that
and every day I would just see in the
shower more thinning and martining and I
don't think enough girls talk about it I
know because it's always like oh it's a
man's problem it's not it's not
some of our hairlines could use some
help some of our hairlines listen
sometimes I spray like stuff colored
stuff in my hair
to make it look like I'm not having thin
hair like I will go to Great Lengths to
to hide it in pictures but I don't want
to hide it in real life you know this is
a real thing it's it's all good it's not
it's and it's not a big deal it's
something that we should all be talking
about and you know but it's something
that's fixable right like
um for me hair is important for my
self-esteem and how I view myself I've
always had very long hair I've always
had long mermaid hair so when that
started going away I started to really
Panic you guys so let's talk about it
your hair story could help another woman
join the conversation at shed the
silence.com that's shed the silence.com
foreign
I'm from Illinois but I grew up in
Southern California okay you are the
Esther oh but you grew up in cheese
Illinois
I don't know what it is I think it's a
suburb okay I was born in Naperville and
then for two years and then we're like
my mom's like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
Neighborville [ __ ] neighbor and then
Southern California where
Camarillo camera oh camera you know
where that is we got Outlets baby
freaking out where the outlets are at
yeah we got them Camarillo
um what do you what's there to do there
outlets and Beach
we had a donut shop too what was your
high school job uh frozen yogurt which
one oh it's called wild cherry and then
did you do it four people or no people
do their own thing you put the no they
would do it themselves and then we still
have the audacity to put a tip jar at
the end people would make their own
[ __ ] and a guy asked me the time he
goes do people people really tip you for
this I was like yeah man yeah I was like
I gotta buy books for school exactly but
this is my basketball team this is
pre-ipad day so this was just one of
coins people just like lob it in there
and make a wish I'm like here you
[ __ ] go I actually don't have it in
me to not tip when they just flip the
iPad even I want to do a Power move and
flip it back to them I'd be like two can
play this game and then just keep I
actually just saw your video about the
Tipping tip one thank you I really liked
I didn't say if I liked it but you just
said thank you but I like
um when is that a mood ring or a promise
ring what is that this is a mood ring
with my dad so a promise ring the first
time me and my dad [ __ ] we decided
let's make it official there you go
um I'm in a good mood are you let's make
it a fish tipping so um I liked the part
where you were in bed with a girl and
you were like she was like what was that
a minute 35 like minute 36 I think it's
a record yeah yes thank you thank you
thank you
um but we had a donut shop and I've
never talked to us but we had a donut
shop in Camarillo and back in the day
girls would show their tits for free
donuts
yeah this is like it was like I want to
spend some fat titties Donuts are really
funny if you get donut holes you're like
damn [ __ ]
this was like 2010 2011 and like that
was the thing did you make it like catch
them in their mouth the holes I don't
know I I was I was always like in the
back like they didn't let me see all
that well how because the hair well the
varsity The Varsity Bros would be like
did you ever throw like a donut hole
through the gauges this is pre-gauge
days okay I thought about it this is um
depending on the rating of the titties
is how many donuts they're given that's
a good point I think I think you aim
high you'd be like let me get a baker's
dozen and then they're like 14 and
you're like and then you just flash like
uh you were hoping he was getting them
free without 12. yeah but then they
stopped doing it but that was like the
place we'd hang out that was like people
would just get drunk there and hang out
at the that was like the after part is
that a 24-hour donut shop was up to like
three or four that is fun three or four
in Camarillo is like I mean that's
that's an all-nighter in Vegas dang we
would hang out at like uh where are you
from IHOP Philadelphia okay IHOP the
suburbs IHOP we'd hang out I think it's
at ihob I remember when they did that
Hub yeah remember when they launched
Burgers
those idiots all marketing God and it
just remember it though it's great yeah
it worked still not going it was
upsetting but it's like Crystal Pepsi do
we give a [ __ ] what is Crystal Pepsi
clear maybe you were still in the Phils
I'm Philly we're both Phillips Clear
Pepsi yeah you've never seen this you
need to grow up kalila I've never seen
this [ __ ] you don't know this
I will tell you a really [ __ ] up Pepsi
story though so
um I don't know if it was we're
sponsored by code that's how we can do
this
um but they're uh Once Upon a Time
sometime in like the early 90s Pepsi did
this um thing where it's like you would
flip the what do you call it like under
the the cap would be like a prize like a
certain amount like you win
but they had a misprint and this
happened in the Philippines and
um like I think it was like 300 people
won the million dollar Prize or
something like that and so they there
they assume like their life had changed
but when they went to go and like
retrieve the money or like present the
cap with a winning thing they were like
oh yeah that was a misprint song no no
no can you pull that up it's like the
Pepsi no no no no I think this is just
marketing but then Pepsi never paid
anyone anything good money how many
people in the Philippines like five six
but this is like an impoverished country
right and here it is it's all marketing
because think about the engagement if I
win a million dollars I'm gonna post
that pepskin on my Instagram like I'm
[ __ ] Rich [ __ ] everyone I'm just
promoting for free that's pretty
marketing okay so so 300.9 incidents I
don't know about that so in in 1992
Pepsi Philippines announced that they
would print numbers
and then how many dude this led to five
deaths you said five right five deaths
how do you what happened people just won
it and they're like [ __ ] yeah and
they're just endorphins killed him or
they killed each other for the cap whoa
that's so [ __ ] sad oh you know
another thing
um our podcast predicts either if people
get together the next week or deaths
like radio people or her ex boyfriend or
her ex guy the guy on the airplane he
died he died absolutely we have to be
careful about I'm getting fingered on an
airplane he rotted finger first wait did
he actually die yeah yeah we found out
here on the show I was like pull up a
picture of him because he was in a cover
band
so I was like pull up a picture because
he's like he was hot but it was like
funny huh he was like cheesy hot cover
band I was like pull him up and they're
like this is his obituary oh no did you
feel any sadness in that that's crazy I
mean I laughed 4K cameras recording your
face reactions be like your ex just died
and you're like this next time watching
my Bluetooth he was a nice guy he was a
really nice guy we had stayed friends
for a while he was a good guy on
tigerbelly we had this whole bit about
Bed Bath and Beyond and what Bobby
thought was like what he considered
Beyond items and then the next week that
like the CFO jumped off like oh yeah
rebuilding so I'm like Beyond
they put his pillows down was it a test
they put the pillows down to see if they
were good it's my favorite Leon Bridges
song beyond beyond he's great singer I
only know one song but I don't remember
what it is but I remember liking it he's
really good um so yeah I think that
everybody's Soulful is that what you're
gonna say yeah I don't know that's crazy
Soulful love it um what are we
predicting now oh well I brought up
Bradley Yoda and he died literally the
next day and then we brought a Brad Pitt
and Brian me getting some [ __ ] Emily
radakowski and then they got together
Trevor's gonna have to take time off
from Comedy because he needs a break
because he's getting so much [ __ ] too
many women girls are you into I like
dark hair brunette
[Applause]
I was kind of looking more at the plant
if you and I had if you and I I know we
have wide eyes so sometimes you can't
tell I can say if you and I put out a
sex tape on only fans right now how much
do you think we'd make
oh my God oh my let's just say this
podcast you guys take Xanax for and do
it you don't have to do it anymore the
brand deals with paper I mean dude you
put one [ __ ] manscape that in that
thing we're talking probably four mil
honestly four mil call crypto.com
probably four mil guys did you see Pete
Davidson's new manscape video no yeah
he's like he's like the face of it they
don't care about us anymore they got
Pete Davidson he's the balls of manscape
no hey
how much money do they have to so much
money I'm telling you so much money is
all over again all the UFC fights I
watch well I wish they were around when
I was but like to even have people there
were bushes in my face hold up a lot of
bushes
yeah the amount of money they had to pay
him for this yeah easy a meal easy no
more than that pizza yeah
will you find out right let's follow
them up because I saw us during the Kim
days I couldn't imagine him like leaving
Kim Kardashian's side to be like I gotta
go film this manscaped and isn't he
getting is it um Kris Jenner his manager
wasn't she for a second oh I would that
would not will you Google at all if
Christian I think it's so interesting
when people have like family members as
managers they're like thermometer but
it's weird when it's like your your
girlfriend's mom I mean right but also
it's Christian I would take it but it's
also like a nice way of keeping the
wealth in the family okay I could see
that but it is also interesting it's
like your dad used to do like sales well
especially if it's like someone like
Kris Jenner who is very much involved in
like the the sale of the sex tape that's
a little weird you know right so you're
like yeah okay looks like it's just
rumors okay just rumors we don't support
rumors yeah yeah we're all about real
news we're about the truth none of this
fake news
or what
you know I'm really [ __ ] I'm just voting
for whoever has the greatest Vibes you
know I just like I like I go on ass
honestly I go you go on what who's got
the best ass oh best ass yeah Trump has
a [ __ ] wagon there's some photos of
him Dolphins he's got hips there's some
photos of him golfing and I mean it's he
got the BBL
this woman who um is alleging that she
orgasmed while she was giving birth to
her baby oh God and that she was in a
state of imagine you had seen that video
I was like on your thing I have that was
like on your uh like how would you feel
if you later find out that as your mom
was birthing you she came all over you
really hard she was coming on you
uh
I'm honestly more interested in what's
going on with you that
this article uh
algorithm is really [ __ ] strange when
I see pregnant things though I do go I
click I go who's pregnant oh manifesting
this show
it's not a fupa guys
um I do think that that it's like what
are you gonna do you can't control the
body it's not like she wanted to do that
oh [ __ ] they do hypnosis yes yes so she
was one of those what does that mean I'm
so I'm new to this like um they like
they rub her nipples when she's giving
birth you know that's what hypnosis I
study hypnosis guys you just rub rub I'm
curious what happened there's there's
there's a you know some women who really
like to go a different route
um during their birth their birth plans
look a little bit different right
they're into you know meditative stuff
like hypnosis stuff and I guess
everything that she had done leading up
to the actual point of Labor
um was done so that she would experience
this Euphoria so there it's premeditated
that you're coming on her baby is
premeditated so I want to know how you
would feel if she's a squirter
squirting was just like water breaking
the whole time
oh wow I uh
but also you have to carry a baby for
nine months let me let me get a nut off
I suppose your mom is telling all of her
friends
that yeah you know when I birth Trevor
when I pushed something so hard is that
why all these kids have nut allergies
it's starting to make sense yeah I would
honestly be I would take that as an
insult because I'd be like oh I must
have been a big baby because if I'm a
fat baby you're pushing you're pushing
you're pushing and you finally get the
ah release I'm like use that as a sound
bite please someone basically you made
your mom come
I mean it wouldn't be the first times it
would
say come on
actually damn it
it's weird there it is can we edit that
back together we don't want yeah
three two one it wouldn't be last time
last track
um I the premeditated part is weird if
you just did it to do it then you're
like whoa that felt amazing look knocked
me up again but I feel like we might
have talked about this on your podcast
but I can't remember you did leave the
Green Day concert without saying goodbye
to me and Todd and I I do want to get to
because it wasn't like it wasn't like uh
did I but here's the thing it wasn't
like uh I realized later you weren't
there it was like ice was like Trev and
you weren't there like it was like Hey
Trev and you guys were all gone were you
high drunk I was drunk okay I was I was
off the alcohol or were you done were
you just like Annie enough you're
talking through Green Day
no I I found like take this lonely pet
and I was like Hey trap was to say
you're a graduate oh okay yeah that's my
bad I kind of juice but I mean like who
sometimes you just had a festival in
your mind it's just like you should go
see if they're still selling churros
like you don't really yeah you did have
45 people with you too you had a you had
enough had a little Entourage it was
cool that's coolest I've ever felt doing
festivals and events like that you do
feel cool well I can't star in his mouth
I do feel like if it hadn't been and
people have like accused me of being too
like delusional but I'm like this
delusion will make me friends with Billy
Joe so I just thought if it wasn't kovid
we would have been able to just be
hanging out with Green Day well I think
we did leave to go see if we can get
back there yeah oh is that what iron are
you going yeah he sent us coffee all the
time apparently he has to he he has a
coffee company called Oakland and we get
coffee all the time really yeah and at
Guitar Picks it's really cute is that
it's kind of rude I know I'm so
allegedly it's a cop Ying we don't open
it we throw it away and the guitar pick
don't forget the guitar pick is what's
is that how you open the coffee like
um yeah I think we had like backstage
passes yeah so we're like oh we're part
of the band they're like we're here no
like this ends here you should have seen
him on shiprocked that's what you got to
get on it's a it's a heavy metal cruise
and Big Jay oakerson does a comedy show
on it really I won it with Seven Dust it
was uh
was on it yeah I hate to say this but
the Sevendust guy is like a friend of
mine also sends you coffee well my joke
was listen my joke on it was well I he
was very nice to me I go oh hold on I go
why are there only two black guys on
this whole cruise and both of them are
the lead singer of Seven Dust that was
one of my jokes is it the black Iron
it's the black guy I thought you were
like when you looked nervous I went oh
she don't know uh-oh no no I do know
um I think his name is um he's the
Darius Rucker of uh heavy metal yeah
what what song are they saying I I I've
known the name I don't know is there one
now
um
on the spot
I'm not sure there's one popular
unfollow her not unfollow me so you're
everything we love you so where does
this where does this Cruise take you to
Tampa there's no way a heavy metal
Cruise once it called were you
performing yes I was yes I was
performance in my lifetime bombed
totally crazy that's why I'm friends
with uh Papa Roach myself so bad that it
was like we became friends
foreign
mine's still green what does that mean
how do you guys open your body that
means you're rich Let's show me oh
you're gonna do the monkey thing what's
the monkey one we're like this is how
they exactly oh no somebody showed me
that you you can just bust the top you
want to see how I do it or you can do
the bottom the top is how Apes do it I
do this
you rip some of your
oh my God
oh my God I mean Todd couldn't be a
luckier man I mean he's at home watching
this being like that's my [ __ ] girl
if you come uncircumcised you leave
circumcised
damn oh this is uh has he ever has he
ever said anything like you know I was a
little much you should probably cut that
I I think it'd be hilarious but if you
guys said that you're like
you're trying to tell me how to do my
show no he um oh like I'm being no I had
a boyfriend once that it's like I don't
want you talking I had this moment in
the middle of the night where I woke up
panicking and I I had a vision of what
it would be like to be sitting in a
coffee shop when I walk into it and I
went oh my God everyone must think I'm
crazy I'm like so loud and annoying like
I just never had thought about what I
looked like through other people's eyes
so I like I like you know startled awake
and my boyfriend like kind of like woke
up and I was like babe am I too much and
he went you're a lot
I only had no card to me that I was like
a psycho
you're a lot that's like a nice way of
kind of agreeing but also being like
yeah you're a little bit you know I had
his girlfriend break up with me
hold up internship break Chief breaks up
with all of her friends but
um like she was like hanging out with
one of my other friends
and she was like she's a lot I thought
that was funny yeah no [ __ ] patches is
fun do you think that's how people
describe you to their other friends like
let's say you're joining a group of
friends that you don't really know and
you're showing up like she's um she
means well she's like a lot but she's
fun
I wonder what people say about me what
do you think people say about you guys
this guy he looks like Annie Letterman
you may know her she's the girl that's a
lot why did you say that like you're
bringing me up at The Comedy Store that
looks like Annie Letterman but I'm just
wondering people like yeah like you
drinks Bud he's fun he's a good hang
he's fun I I like to I just uh linked my
friend up with another friend of mine
and the way I described her sexually
good energy no I think he needed he
needed a date to some functions oh nice
it wasn't like a sexual like link up or
anything like that but I called her like
I accidentally called her like a good
time girl but that's really how I feel
inside I'm like she's such a good time
but I called her a good time girl and he
was like like that I don't know what you
mean by that they're like yeah she's a
good time girl I get that
um but it sounded really sexual and I
felt immediately bad I'm like oh I might
well it's weird it's weird to hook up
two friends and not think there might be
some sexual chemistry that's like
there's Bumble BFFs shut up go [ __ ] oh
I'm so disgusted wait what is that just
friends on like Ryan you swiped hang out
with people
lonely go to Pilates it's like you have
the option to just be friends is that
what it is yeah I guess but it's like I
think that but that's like networking
then it's like you're scared you're
afraid I I feel like people do that
because it's less intimidating but
they're like yeah we're just boys and
then they like slowly but that's crazy
you have some banana on your lip oh let
me lick it off since I've been seeing
these
um like uh women groups where the
they're like if you don't have like a
friend group you can join this trip
everyone's going to Spain for 10 days
and it's like no one you know no huh no
it's that sounds like a [ __ ]
nightmare for me I think you would
probably find like one or two other
people on there you enjoy but the rest
are like [ __ ] you would have to
one person who also dislikes the same
people you dislike right that would be
the only way to talk [ __ ] and that's how
you probably Bond but look at this
[ __ ] truck but the girl that friend
of me that's how we became friends is we
talked [ __ ] on all the same people and I
and it was like
well it's a commonality because it would
happen but I knew it would happen to me
yeah there was a revolving time I mean
eventually the the barrel was going to
be staring me down but but now you have
a big platform and you can talk [ __ ]
about her and then other people who know
her that listen but I agree does she
have a platform too not a very big one
no damn you win
[ __ ] around how did I don't I've never
ended a friendship and told somebody
like you just stopped talking oh yeah
well she she was like Madam this is
another thing that's annoying I hate
when like because every time I've been
friend dumped like three times and
there's always what one was in high
school you got to be try being a girl
um one was in high school
um and she was like we grew apart and I
was like but she announced but she was
like yeah what just stop talking to me
you know yeah like she was like my best
friend so I was like I was active oh
best friends interesting I was I mean
she and it was funny because we had all
these friends in high school
these mutual friends and
um so she went off to college she was
like a year ahead of me she went off to
college she wrote me this letter I wish
I still had it it was just about how
much she loved me how amazing I was like
how she she's like I feel like I'm
writing her eulogy you're just like so
incredible I love the way you're just
yourself all the time you're crazy in
public there is a book no no it was all
like you're incredible yeah then she
went to college
and she became like a hipster like she
started she went to University of
Michigan and she became like she started
hanging out with people that were like
and I'm not if you go to I'm not for you
like the people that are like like
expecting something from you I'm not the
one if you just make just letter noises
if you like read and think that's cool
when people go off to college and come
back and change that checks out that
makes sense dude I went to uh college
for a semester it was in a frat came
back everybody stayed in my hometown I
was like you guys don't matter to me you
guys don't know how to beer bong Natty
Ice at 4am I know what about you're
buying Natty Ice do you oh my God yeah
this was my
it's for fun yeah
in college because I mean at in college
you wanted to be picked yes of course
why wouldn't you black out from Nadia
but I didn't know how to be picked me
like so I would just like like I just
they just thought I was a lesbian like I
would just be like come on Bros like I
was like you know like I'm like one of
you I'd be right like a white house it
was like a slight line I mean I told you
this like I was such a pick me up my
friends were like [ __ ] me I actually I
mean I would watch like MMA fights and
boxing and be really really like into it
that I accidentally like ended up loving
it you know like Pete put it in her ass
and let's see what happens should I you
have me you're really growing on me I
can't
there's already something in there
oh the gerbil
we don't want to drown that guy
um somebody just coming back we were
like I am better than you guys well
people that don't leave their Hometown
like God bless you but if you are one of
the people that does leave and you come
back and people haven't left are like
you're not
strive you're not striving
there's not a lot to talk about you go
how is everything go well I just had my
fourth kid and you're like cool oh my
God so many kids yeah kids but I feel
like that is an indicator of maybe a
friendship that really never was because
okay my childhood friends like when I
see them no matter how different our
lives are there's like kind of like a
quiet Nostalgia that of like just being
around them like we don't have to catch
up we don't have we don't care where
we're at in our life yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're just gonna hang out in silence
because like we always did as friends
like there's no expectation of anything
my best friend
uh with my neighbor he has two daughters
he's a he does like kitchens like
it's like remodeling yeah he's like a
kitchen guy okay yeah no he just does
tiles and stuff oh yeah yeah he's got
rough hands yeah oh nice yeah oh he
wanted me to hook him up with Stella oh
because that's my future girlfriend I
was like no she has a boyfriend that's
every DM I've gotten this week oh she
was on our podcast yes she do stretchy
butthole she was like I just have a
stretchy butthole that's so funny to be
her reasoning no I remember she said
she's like I just haven't stretchy she's
like once he has the first ring of the
anal glands it just kind of just goes
[ __ ] iCloud what do you mean but yeah
she I mean I was fascinated analogous
I just had dinner with that's why you
guys broke up two days ago you had
dinner with her yeah cause she did our
show and then she did tigerbelly and we
all went out to eat and stuff but she
really just is like so like fascinating
because she's so normal she's very smart
she's really smart but then she went
from growing up in Montana and then
doing High School in London so she has
like so much like weird life experience
for being so young what did she eat was
she wore
I was concerned about that too like you
have to worry about what you eat and
then she's like got some Whole Foods I'd
be like I'm eating rice cakes and rice
we ate Korean food and she didn't know
what anything was on the table but she
gobbled it up and I was like yeah that's
my kind of girl was her boyfriend in
town
um yeah but he didn't come to dinner it
was just her me and a couple other
people okay because I was gonna say
maybe my boyfriend's out of town her
[ __ ] on the smoke break who knows no
but earlier that day she said that she
just did an anal bead video no she she
was like I had a question about her
lifestyle and she goes oh I can just
show you and then she holds her phone
and it's just a video
but in real life I've seen a video she
showed me she should and the dude that
she's dating was just in it it like it
it literally looked like ring footage
like the camera was just like from a
distance and I was like oh oh first
round ring footage I hate to tell you
guys this it's another Green Day coffee
moment but she showed me her [ __ ] and
it was like this close to my face
like not camera but real ass yeah and
then she like asked to see like my [ __ ]
and I showed her like my full blast
[ __ ] yeah and she was like oh in this
room not here like uh hanging out
outside of here oh did you just like do
anything oh my God her face is getting
red this is hot they're amazing
we both determined that we would
definitely have sex with each other when
where is pushing what's the website yeah
[ __ ] tiger belly just do that no I love
talking about that [ __ ] tiger balance it
does come no no just just do it oh hold
on yeah I mean what are we talking about
patreon put it on patreon put it on a
paywall
I hope the camera only gets the top of
your hair oh yeah
that's like three inches on that [ __ ]
right there
um wow we had a very different podcast
experience with her she came by was very
wholesome did an hour and a half showed
me a video and then left wow that's
still pretty didn't show us anything
which is fine right I didn't want to did
she have her feet exposed for blow
no she did not are you both foot fetish
guys no no no I'm normal yeah yeah I
know it's like someone only Michael is
right yeah loves the feet I have so many
questions for him I really really do
come on the podcast
Annie has coined the term feed and greet
and
um you know she's preserved her fee she
always pixelates her feet and yeah it
really is like yeah one million I think
that's a prize and what do they get with
that one picture of my feet standard
checks out I would pay that
but is there tears to it like two
million you get to you gotta use Nike
sock
no but that's a good idea
let's throw it out there someone I'm
good at business you know that's what
it's all about you got to just level up
because somewhat you like I know it's
like jokingly like a million but there's
some guy right now in Kuwait being like
of course [ __ ] they're like should I do
that should I block change oh man you
know I I mean I don't know well you know
what's also funny is that girls get
taxed on the only fans money that's the
government be like let me get some of
that [ __ ] money yes let me get some of
that [ __ ] payment
I'm still eating the noodles I mean
we're a minute 47 here those aren't warm
at all I'm tiny bit really they do look
so good great insulation in there
you gotta try chapaghetti
chapaghetti is the best
what is that
it sounds warm
probably Getty Rhymes spaghetti chopped
up spaghetti yeah so it's basically it
sounds delicious have you ever had
spaghetti and accidentally chokes you
never again enjoy some chapaghetti
tapas why did you say like it was an ad
deal right there enjoy chapsticks
minded It's like a bean paste with like
noodles it's like Asian obviously but
you know they just call it chapaghetti
it's like but oh that's really good if
you look at the picture of it it's it's
it comes with a DC like that like oh
papa delivers it too yeah
I want some Ramen that sounds great
right now ah yeah but also Ramen like
100 degree weather is insane is it 100
degrees though out it's warm but if
you're sitting outside you're eating
you're sweating I'm like Weather Blind
unless something horrific happens to me
like I don't know like if I go to the
car and I come back in and Todd's like
is it like cold or hot out I'm like I
have no clue I like don't mother blend
also it's California you'll be fine with
whatever you want that's also because
you and I sweat not according to the
weather yeah I'm always wear our own
like gauge because her and I like are
pit sweaters like excessive pit sweaters
need the pillow no dude I think you need
the pillow and so it doesn't matter if
it's like in the dead cold in the Arctic
I'm still if I'm feeling some type of
way or nervous forget it it's like a
whole pit stain really I'm in fighter
constant fighter flight if I'm relaxed
in like equatorial weather I wouldn't
sweat a drip so it's like yeah
guys you'll never hear me saying
equatorial I only got my sweat is when
someone's like how do you spell
equatorial yeah cute I got nothing
do you think you'd be good at a spelling
bee no okay that's true
never played nerdle what's nerdle nerdle
it's instead of Wordle it's math problem
oh [ __ ] but like I say t ones are just
like 28 divided by three daily like
oh it's like Mental Math it's fun oh
yeah this is too much
they're running succession
what the [ __ ] is this you have to just
guess what the equation is oh you just
and then you have to solve it but it has
to be the right
now what the hell is happening what is
this calculator this is [ __ ]
pressing random numbers here oh okay
yeah this makes sense it's just with
numbers
nope it's math it has to be an equation
that works what is the [ __ ]
plus wait wait that guest does not
compute Pete you have to do like 12. you
have to do like 12 plus this is dumb you
play this six equals my dad I see I see
it my 81 year doubt any 81 year old dad
crushes this
uh is your dad retired right something
else well I don't know my dad's newly
retired and he just sends me just memes
photos articles everything I was 15.
really yeah wow now he sold his feet
picks huh yeah well he retired he had he
was offered early retirement and he got
like a good deal he used to work at Penn
they got like a new president and they
wanted all new staff so they were giving
people like good you guys think you'll
work forever
are you always gonna work oh that is a
good question someone asked me that they
said how much money would you have to
make to just walk away from stand up oh
wow
20 mil that's it yeah
I don't I don't know because I think you
just get bored if I think you always
want to do a stand-up right I think you
probably will give up stand up but find
some other creative way to still Express
comedy like how George Bush paints
pictures now yeah the victims of the war
oh no yes or of dogs I can't remember
see their dogs are the victims of war
it's friends Michelle Obama George he
does George Bush does paintings now yeah
they're not bad what the [ __ ] what this
is the last memory I have with him is
painting not doing 9 11. I would rather
the painting look at him
interesting yeah I don't know I used to
get bored that's you know that's why
everybody who like wins the lottery goes
bankrupt in like a year they're like I
did it on board give me back at [ __ ]
H R Block are there any
Big Time lottery winners with um happy
endings
it's not happy uh there's maybe like one
or like that know how to do it I was I
saw some articles the Asian and say that
that was a real [ __ ] up most of them
blow it all quickly I don't think
anybody wins a lottery and they're like
we should invest
[Music]
he won the lottery he didn't he won uh
fantasy football he won a million
dollars and then he won a hundred
thousand dollars the next time and he
immediately invested all of it but he's
not like he's not someone that's like
they scratch off tickets gonna change my
life you know I am such an anxious
person that if something like that back
to back like two good things happen to
me back like I'm about to die yeah I'm
about to die looking around the corner
for something because I'm too anxious
when I I but I also think maybe like
maybe he'll run out of luck afterwards
maybe he's one more lucky moment or
maybe life is good for him for the rest
of the time he's on here well I believe
he's married he's got a cute dog he's
like one of the nicest people yeah he's
really nice I feel like maybe you know
but he okay so
um what was I gonna say how much would
it take for you to just stop doing it I
don't think I would ever stop doing it
that's kind of where I'm at I I love it
I enjoy it I've always liked doing it I
did it when I was like broke as [ __ ]
it's like sweet I'm making money from it
now but I never was no I enjoy it it's
yeah it's yeah I don't think we have to
make sure it's still relatable right
right that must have been weird the
first time Rogan did a show after that
Spotify deal he's like uh you ever just
get a can of beans like no talk about
the 100 million dollars you have sitting
in your bank account right right now
talk about it what is the dumbest thing
you've spent money on I remember when I
I really thought I was on I made these
shirts that ended up getting cease and
assist from White cloth I made this
video about white claw and I sold these
t-shirts that had a quote on it and uh
uh they in in two days they sold seven
thousand t-shirts so we're we're talking
your boy was up but it was a pre-order I
didn't end up getting a dollar from it
right no because the company sent their
legal team was like you have to return
all these t-shirts or else we're gonna
hit you with here here here and here
right so ended up having to return it
right didn't make a dollar
um how much would that have translated
into like 100k yeah like but but I was
like 25 at the time I would have been
like so but when I saw all these orders
coming in I think I ordered like a 125
meal from like lemonade on Postmates
yeah you know how hard it is to get a
bill for one person to 125 I mean it was
getting like matcha and [ __ ] I didn't
even like like wheat grass shots I mean
I was like send it all yeah well I okay
so I I look at money as energy now so I
don't look at money like when I'm
ordering things and who knows maybe this
ends up with me in bankruptcy I don't
think it will though but
um because there's a million ways to
make money and I think once you can like
unleash that you realize there's
literally like a million things you
could do yeah but um I feel like
when I order food I just like don't like
I used to worry about how much it costs
now just order whatever I want I know
you order that way right like you guys
order like everything you would want to
eat right that uh that's Bobby's but
Bobby's way is a little funny so he
orders a lot more than
um more than he can actually consume
right but he doesn't he used to not
allow me to take leftovers which is
a fight we order a lot but this is gonna
sustain me right for the whole week but
he's like no I spent the money you don't
get to take [ __ ] home that's so funny
because his thing is kind of wild yeah
it's somehow in his head it's more of
like a power trip it's like if I pay for
it it's my food I am just letting you
eat it what if he was like you can have
it but I have to feed it too I mean yeah
you actually would like that yeah I
would are you kidding me him showing
love
I'll take it I also bought a Rolex that
was pretty irresponsible I never wear it
kind just like the cheapest one Oyster
Perpetual remember uh Louie's joke when
he was like like when he lost like I
don't know 50 what did he lose in one
day I don't remember what the joke was
but he lost an exorbitant amount of
money in one day when all the canceling
started happening it was I have three
gold watches like what was I thinking
yeah I mean it's it's I don't I hardly
ever wear it because I don't want to
wear it on stage because I don't want
people like oh this [ __ ] [ __ ] then
I don't want to wear around town because
yeah you don't get shot I'm frail and
some guy goes oh nice watch mine now
right so now I just I don't but I just
don't have a safety deposit I don't know
what to do with it I'll probably end up
just selling it back but watches do hold
their they really do I was gonna say
they really really do I watch enough
fantasy it's really like you'll go to
like an event and wear it yeah exactly
because even on like a date you feel
like you're like oh let me just get the
bill and then just slam it on the table
that's actually a Nick for me real big
fancy one again
um oh wow but what if it's a really hot
arm in hand it doesn't matter
um real big fancy watches if it's more
of like it's it's a Slimmer one it's
slim it's not too much I'm watch I wore
in college that I don't know what it is
about being like 22 but you'll wear a
[ __ ] a Flavor Flav watch on your
wrist we all did that with the Michael
Kors ones yeah oh yeah the rose gold
like the bigger the better the heavier
wrists
it would like oversee overshadow my like
wrist like it was in a like it was so
messy right right and for some reason I
was like women will like this I could go
back to a watch I love watches but I
wear a lot of Swatch watches which also
hold their value
I I like it I just I don't know I never
wear it yeah these are a little bit too
um big for me the Michael Kors watches
were I did like the big like boyfriend
one yeah yeah which one was that it was
just like a big like gold hangy watch
yeah I think I still like it I don't
know I don't even feel busted out
it wasn't that expensive it's not you
can't rob me for it I know because
Todd's gonna propose to me and I'm like
I want to I want an expensive ring but
then I'm like you know
no I have no clue okay at first I
thought we established he might do it in
Mexico but Mexico's Kansas Mexico's
canceled whatever and also he told me he
was gonna do in Mexico I was like you
now can't do anything if you propose to
a girl Trevor are you gonna kind of like
drop some hints or anything yeah I'd go
surprise surprise he told you maybe he's
doing that to buy time well he thought
he thought he was like he was like you
know maybe something Fun's gonna happen
in Mexico or whatever I don't know what
maybe you want me in my name like my
anal beads what are we talking here
because the girls really there are I
really do care about but my nails are
always done you're right and especially
if I'm going to like a
like hey if my nails aren't like I don't
think it needs to be like it honestly
could be at Ralph's like I don't care
but I would like there to be a surprise
it would be so refreshing if a girl just
posted a picture of nails like mine
for all purposes I can't deal with it no
no not with it but I'm happy for you the
ladies that propose to the men and you
guys are happy I want you to live your
best life I am I can't I can't how do
you feel about Disneyland proposals no
well I kind of don't like Disneyland so
it would be funny to do it to me though
oh yeah I think that's always funny if
they're if because every you know you
have this picture of what the beautiful
wedding day looks like but it is funny
to be like hey there's a turkey leg yeah
now I'm on one leg oh yes anyone were to
do a public proposal I would never marry
him because he just doesn't know me at
all how do you feel about ones on stage
have you ever had that somebody the
first show I did on the last tour in
New Orleans somebody proposed to their
their their lady
and did she like it yeah I mean I don't
know I didn't talk to him was that what
part of the show at the end yeah yeah
it's hard to like do that up top and
then be like okay I'm traveling a lot
yeah but uh yeah I I think public ones
are interesting yeah I do too it's like
in it I mean Outdoors of families around
that's one thing but like public ones
it's like you're so not that Todd is
listening right now but what is your
perfect what's the person
how does it look like what I thought I
wanted was I want him to propose me on
my family vacation because I thought my
nieces would like freak out wait did you
expect it on your last family vacation
no because I was on the phone with his
mom and she was like Tyler you did not
get the ring and I was like yes he I'm
sure he got it and he's she's like no
like I'm like what Todd
how long you've been dating
like a little bit before the pandemic so
like three years
yeah nice but I mean it's gonna happen
it doesn't matter but it's like it
really is absolutely I want a huge do I
want a very expensive ring or not is
really what's keeping us
I'm kind of over Diamond I think I might
be over it wow this is great this is
great Every Woman isn't it like and I
started to do lab but isn't it better
for the environment and like yeah you're
getting a [ __ ] purity ring
a little bit [ __ ] basic I'm not
talking about cheese
basic but there's like but I do like I
do like a pear-shaped solitaire diamond
like a little [ __ ] a big ass like
little that's not I'm thinking but it's
basic can you look up pear shapes yeah
I'm not curious don't get too excited
though Trevor because what I want is
might be more expensive are you guys
gonna regularly together really yeah
yeah I'm taking like rubies wait
sapphires I heard Sapphire is uh very
expensive wait can I push something
somebody told me sapphires well Esther's
gone can we just have like a rotating
guest and see if you Vibe with them if
we Vibe is this a dating show it might
be did it just well I do so I would I
wouldn't have even gone there but
because I'm I like to respect people's
relationships but I'm like kind of
excited about but not that you guys are
aren't I'm just like excited about the
prospects I know we aren't already I
feel like maybe there's a box yeah she's
not into rings she's not wearing one
today
we could also probably share a ring I
have such frail fingers you could easily
like you're doing this learning because
you're being self-deprecating oh yeah
you're telling me ahead of time my time
with five of these in you just to finger
you regular oh
but with just a regular band with just a
regular oh that's an almond
I know like just like that you like how
what is that wrong but I like it I don't
know classic classic it looks like it
would stab your finger no I think my
friends like you don't really want a big
ring because it gets caught on your
pants and stuff no I met a girl last
weekend and she had a ring that had a
knife that popped out of it she's like
it's LA and I was like it's kind of hot
I really want that home the company that
makes that sense
but it was like it had a flat top then
you click a little side and then [ __ ]
yep top left could it really stab okay
it's only yeah well it's only eight
dollars so oh you probably won't I want
a better one yeah I don't know but but
it I mean it'd be great for like
shotgunting a beer I think but but yeah
poisoning somebody look at that point I
like the 400 one look at that one the
gold one that pops up oh yeah that's a
good one but I had no idea I love it you
want to see some cool things I was like
a [ __ ] out tiny it's like you're
bleeding out the tiniest bit yeah
imagine she's jerking you off and then
oh my God oh my God as I said you can
come uncircumcised I would come hard
yeah I didn't know there was a thing
though oh it's that one right there
sometimes it's a joke instead of a sense
what the [ __ ] is going on something
you're defending yourself with 66 cents
you just throw a quarter at him instead
sometimes instead of a cockering I use
um those things for um cigars the chop
the top
is that bad is that bad it's kind of
arousing actually
yeah I don't know wait I love wait is
this no I'm not going to say that to two
recently single people but you're
probably happy to be what I was just
gonna say I love like having my person
and not having to date no I I I I
definitely get lonely at times I
definitely miss but that's not what I
mean like I don't I wasn't meaning to
like say that to you guys but I was like
you're just flexing I'm never the one
like I just it's so great having
somebody to hold me no I'm usually in an
abusive relationship like I'm usually
like watching like when I saw stars born
I was like weird I was like I'm
uncomfortable this feels real like oh
um no you found your person I found
myself always together news are always
like like I picture you guys together
yeah [ __ ]
um there's a big pause and I was like
did this just get weird no it didn't get
weird but no you're right there are
people or couples that I look at I'm
like I just cannot picture them [ __ ]
and you can picture us totally we yeah
we have we have our signature move which
is everyone's heard it so much but why
not does it also involved yes each guest
gets to hear it um the hospital bed
where we we bring the hospital I sit on
the edge of the hospital bed and then he
like me up
I'm leasing my place right now and his
parents used to visit a lot so he has an
electric chair that goes up the stairs
oh my God that's awesome I've never done
sexual activities on it
yet I need a Life Alert or something but
yeah it'd be so slow like the girls like
up there like with their mouth open it's
like yeah it's too slow to make it
sexual it's it's yeah it's not good for
that but it's just fun it just goes up
the stairs I love yep yep that's awesome
so I still have one of those and uh yeah
that's actually most people have like a
cool like painting people have like
Esther would be so jealous no it's like
that's the centerpiece people walk in
and they go like [ __ ] that couch you
spent two thousand dollars on what is
that over there one year for my birthday
there it is I think I was turning 30 or
something it was one of those birthdays
where people are like you're afraid
you're getting old my friend got me like
uh one of those portable like toilets
that all people have no and it was
really and then I opened it and she had
drawn a doo-doo and it said like you're
the [ __ ] or something it was really good
but it was a really good camping ones
that's cute no no it's like you got it
it's like it's like it's like a walker
yes with a toilet in it and I peed I did
no flush just Bowl yeah you gotta have a
cleaner Todd would clean it for me he's
a good boy that's real he's a good boy
wow would you say you're the dominant
one in the relationship yes yes does he
know this yes okay but he's still a man
he's my man there we go I like that yeah
it works
I love him so it was one of these yeah I
was just saying you like why does it
look like the two legs up to the side
yeah it's like is it nervous yeah he's
like look at my butthole it's like what
Stella did to her it's How Stella was
like look look at me but it is yeah
bedside commodes we have to clean it out
which uh yeah
you know it defeats a purpose because
you're still sitting in it then you're
still Wheeling around the house
it's just Grandma's [ __ ] storms just
going through the hallways
somebody cleaned my ass
at what point did you stop wiping your
own ass
as soon as you don't you don't have to
as soon as you don't have to that's also
true no if I was Joe
because like to draw I'm like when I'm
rich I'm gonna have like this person do
this and he's like no he's always like
you want to keep your circle small I'm
like do you want to give yourself what
is one thing that if you had all just
[ __ ] you money that you would splurge on
oh wow like like because for instance
like an ass wiper someone who just oh oh
like around yeah they're real Splurge I
want a living bidet I want it to be a
small Frenchman that used to be a jockey
yeah I want to give up I want to give a
jockey who's out of work a job you come
be my bidet you stay in that toilet you
lick my [ __ ] clean go ahead I just
want somebody to be a a second pair of
hands for me I think the human body
needs to evolve we still have two hands
this is [ __ ] boring give me a fourth
right yeah so I would have somebody
probably Thomas yeah I'm horned up but I
would have somebody like crack their rib
maybe no just like I want like like
there's times when I'm like carrying too
much [ __ ] in from the house and then I
also have like a coffee and I'm like I
don't know like bouncing on my neck yeah
that's a living Shadow but you don't
want another person there you just want
right I just want their hands yeah but
like hot hands so when I look down I see
like oh [ __ ] and then when you're
jerking off it's like yeah when I'm
drinking off I can still be on a zoom
call Big hey how you guys doing yeah you
know I I think another pair of like hot
like white French tip nails like on my
sides yeah because then when I don't
want it to be seen I can just tuck them
into like a large teeth I love a French
tip I love it hug me yes I need those
lately they just hug you when you you
don't want to oh I'm alone yeah
um does Blau ever hug you
yeah but he's pretty frail too so yeah
it's like bone on bone that is cute you
guys are he's a he's great I love him he
helps me a lot you know I I really
really didn't want to say this out loud
I've been trying to not say this out
loud since the first day I met you but
you really look like my dead stepbrother
that I had sex with bro
there's certain things we have to tell
people when they come on the show before
before
um
actually
um
I was uh wait so how did this happen
because I had a friend who's I had a
friend date this girl back in high
school he they were both dating and then
their parents started hooking up then
their parents got married and then
because of that they're like well I
don't think we should [ __ ] right
that's exactly what happened so it got
weird but I hate to say it but like ah
because he was my stepbrother after but
he had a really perfect penis
foreign
you were just that close to the door or
there was like a glory hole or it was
facing and my bedroom my head would face
the window and he climbed through my
window and he one morning I guess I
didn't text him back in time and he just
came and cracked it we deserved like a
punch me down
sock and Bop and robot what is it he
just you're like I'm not gonna text you
back now
he punched me away you should have been
with another dude then the dude catches
the fist he's like what's up that's
right you need a gym damn when was when
was the whole stepbrother Fiasco when
was this oh so this wasn't even like a
porn category yet mm-hmm it's very super
confusing because imagine when your
stepdad or your mom actually starts
dating
um you're you know but can't you be like
I got dibs first on this family this is
your stepdad now he's still my stepdad
no and he was my high school history
teacher so they met during like back to
school night my mom and him did you guys
pretty much brought them together yeah
yeah and but then his son and I were
friends so we were like oh yeah you
should meet so and it's just this ain't
like the movie Mr Nobody with Jared Leto
I've never went to Jared Leto's best
movie have you seen it Mr Nobody
everybody check it out I've seen the
cover of it it's like parallel lives
that he lived in one of the lives he was
established is in love with uh his
stepsister yeah I mean it really is sort
of like they were like into each other
and then their parents started dating
and then they like were like here and
then they had to like break up but
basically it's like I got the ick right
as soon as my mom and my stepdad got
together I got the ick but then he
didn't so like there was a period there
where it was like weird and he was like
real sad about it but I'm like no like
yeah and then you'd still see each other
at like family events or no I went to
college and I didn't see him again for
like two years and then he ended up um
uh
well I mean I get friend broken up with
so I understand yeah you know same boats
but you know what the friend breakup
things that I was gonna say is
this is what I don't like I don't like
when no one will just tell you what's
happening like they they'll break up
with you I guess this happens in
relationships too but I had one friend
who was like this was a guy and he was
like I heard you talking [ __ ] on me and
I went what and he was I can't tell you
and I go what is it and then he goes
we're done but what was I talking about
I think they say that because they want
you to say right so I'll be like well
did I say you were fat yeah yeah
but I was like I don't know what because
I don't if I'm if I was talking [ __ ] on
him it wasn't anything I made up you
know what I mean I'm like what honest
things I heard you were talking [ __ ]
yeah like what happened to people just
ghosts if you can go so many
relationship just goes to French oh she
said something [ __ ] up but it was fine
it was all good I didn't care that much
but it was just I just was like annoyed
by that because it was that thing I was
thinking about like what if I was like
oh I called you you know like I just
like something that I that he never knew
I said and then he was like if I tell
you
what you said then you're gonna go to
the person that told me mad at them and
I was like what when was this this it
was recently and he was 50 years old he
was a 50 year old man that's hilarious
isn't that so weird that's hilarious but
it's okay like worry about your
arthritis what are you talking about mom
would say pathetic but that thick but
dead but I have recently realized I
don't care anymore like if people are
mad at me about something and they don't
want to tell me what it is yeah that's a
you thing not at me you just go on with
you okay you keep living how you live I
don't care yeah you can't care guys guys
friend breakups are not you don't have
to announce yourself let's put an end to
that yeah just ghosts if you want
something in your life you'd let them
know but also you can announce but just
say what the actual thing is
you don't have to be like cryptic about
it yeah I mean I've taken like breaks
from people where they're like hey like
why aren't we you know like I feel like
I'm it is more one-sided and I'm like
you know what it's just um a lot of
essays from you I'm just not maybe
emotionally available I don't have the
bandwidth to kind of like be at the
moment I hope you can understand like
stuff like that but never like a lot of
buzzwords right there so it's two of my
two of my friend requests were like I
heard what you said I'm like what what
did I say what are these like you don't
tell I'm like are these like people you
know from like Philly or like people
these are like newer La friends oh where
I'm just like okay okay I don't know
it's just funny to be 50. I mean you
hurt my feelings if I talk sooner it was
probably publicly so send me the clip
yeah let me post it I probably [ __ ]
you up that bad I'm gonna do on Tick
Tock get the numbers up well thank you
so much thank you guys for having me did
you get it through all your notes
oh this is a set list from the other
night
uh but no I didn't I'll go through them
right now edit it out edit it out he's
off the cuff he doesn't have a setlist
uh no setlist yeah I talked about
everything I wanted to on here
um thanks for having me it's been
awesome I think you want to plug promote
I'm on tour right now I'm gonna be in a
bunch of cities from California to
Florida all of them uh
travelwellscomedy.com get some tickets
you guys do it now and stiff socks stiff
sock my podcast yeah we'd love to have
you on
um yeah every Wednesday
sir
[Music]
[Music]